mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
a circle contains triangle abc
from each side of the triangle construct
the perpendicular bisector of the side
and connect it to the boundary of the
circle
these line segments have lengths of 1 2
and 3. the problem is to calculate the
area
of triangle abc when i was shown this
problem
these were the answer choices presented
to me
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
[Music]
problem
[Music]
while the problem seems to be simple
it's actually an extraordinarily
difficult geometry problem
so let's work through it step by step
first
extend the perpendicular bisector of
each side
they will meet at a single point known
as the circumcenter of the triangle
and this will be the center of the
circle we will then consider
each side in turn first consider the
side a
which is opposite angle a
suppose the circle has a radius equal to
r
since this entire length goes through
the center of the circle
we will have a diameter of the circle
therefore
this line segment will be equal to 2r
minus 2.
because the chord bc is bisected each
half will be equal to a
over two we then use the intersecting
chords theorem
we have a over two multiplied by a over
two
is equal to two r minus two multiplied
by two
we can use this equation to solve for a
we want the positive value because
a should be a positive length
from here we will do a similar
calculation to solve for the length
of the side which has a length equal to
b
here this length will be equal to two r
minus three and each of these will be
equal to b over two
we thus have b over two multiplied by b
over two is equal to two r minus three
multiplied by three just as before we
solve for the value of b
and we take the positive square root
we finally do the same sort of
calculation to find the length c
of the remaining side using the
intersecting chords theorem we get the
following equation
and then we can solve for the length c
we again
take the positive length from here what
do we do
well let's take a look at just this
triangle and consider
angle a we can use elkashi's law of
cosines to solve for the cosine of angle
a
we have a squared is equal to b squared
plus c squared minus 2bc
multiplied by cosine of angle a we thus
solve for the cosine of angle a
and we've already solved for a b and c
so we can substitute those values in
we're going to need to do a little bit
of algebra but once we do that we can
solve
that cosine of a is equal to the
following
from there what are we going to do well
recall that sine squared of a
is equal to 1 minus cosine squared of a
we can thus solve for the sine of
a after we do quite a bit of algebra and
some simplification
we get that sine of a is the following
we thus have the following expressions
all in terms of the radius r
the area of this triangle will be equal
to one-half
multiplied by side b multiplied by side
c
multiplied by the sine of angle a
we substitute these values in and we get
an expression for the area
in just the term r so all that remains
will be to solve
for the radius of the circle how can we
do that
we are going to use l2c's law of sines
this states that two times the radius of
the circle
will be equal to a over the sine of a
we can substitute these values in and we
get that 2r is equal to the following
from here we simplify and we get a cubic
equation
how can we solve this cubic equation i
myself wouldn't be able to solve
this so i looked it up to find some neat
tricks we're first going to make a
depressed cubic
if we have a cubic in the following form
we can make the following substitution
so let's make this substitution r is
equal to x plus two
if we substitute this in it simplifies
to x cubed
minus three x minus one is equal to zero
this is called a depressed cubic because
we've eliminated
the squared term from here
we're going to make another substitution
suppose x
is equal to 2 times the cosine of t
if we substitute that in we get the
following equation
we then use the clever substitution that
the cosine
of the triple angle three times t is
equal to the following
so we can substitute that in we get two
times the cosine
of three t minus one is equal to zero
we thus get that cosine of 3t is equal
to one-half
and we have a family of values for t
we want to take exactly three of them
because we have a cubic equation
so t can either be equal to pi over 9 7
pi
over 9 or 13 pi over nine
let's evaluate each value of t since
r is equal to x plus two and x is equal
to two cosine of t
r is equal to two plus two cosine of t
we thus have the three possibilities for
the value of r
and we get the following approximate
values
now recall the area involves the square
root
of two r minus three since we want the
area to be a positive value
we must have 2r minus 3 is a positive
value
this means r is greater than 3 over 2
which is equal to 1.5
we can therefore eliminate the
approximate value of 0.47
this case will not be a solution to the
original problem
we thus go to the following two values
now the second possibility that's
approximately 1.65
will lead to the following values for
the sides which will be the following
construction
and if you work out the perpendicular
bisector lengths
you end up with the following case which
was different from the original problem
so this again is not a solution to the
problem
we are thus left with a single value for
r
and that's the value we want we
substitute that into our area expression
and we get the following it's an exact
value for the area
in terms of the cosine of pi over nine
i think this is a really incredible
formula and it's approximately equal to
17.19
now if we go back to the original
problem we were given the following
answer choices
it made the problem seem like it would
be a simple problem and there must be
an easy way to solve it but in fact all
of these
answers are wrong so i think this
problem presents an important life
lesson you can't make the right choice
if you have the wrong options but if you
mind your decisions
you can solve anything
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
see you next episode as we solve the
world's problems
one video at a time
you